well first she's incredible one time  American Idol host Ryan Seacrest weighs  in on rumors that the original winner  herself Kelly Clarkson could become a  judge on ABC's reboot of Idol she was so  remarkable and sincere and lovely when  she came on in the last season's I think  she would make a fantastic job  eg caught up with Ryan outside the live  with Kelly and Ryan studios in New York  a big question now would Ryan host idol  again the show originally filmed across  the country in Los Angeles we're still  talking about it was funny because I  read the Grammys we're coming to you are  catch this would be an easier  conversation if if I don't worry in New  York but that's not my decision  [Music]